hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead episode 13 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet so much fun watching
Carol make MacGyver cookies although
really it was Maggie that went all
rageface it's been a while since we've
seen her like that cuz she totally got
that woman to stop smoking sure it was
by turning her brains into jelly but it
was probably the best anti-smoking ad
ever see what happens when you smoke you
get your face bitten off you get turned
to jelly and burned alive missus brought
to you by the walking dead and a couple
comic book things to explain and top 10
WTF so I will say a new round of the
giveaway starts now all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so here we go top
10 WTF number 10 Maggie wants to finish
the savior off no we got to finish this
she said that a couple times during the
episode she is hardcore but I think it
was just the idea that Glenn was in
trouble the kick turned to that it's not
like pregnancy hormones have made her
crazy or anything you have to remember
that she was already really crazy number
9 WTF amazing use of claustrophobic
camera underneath the hood just using
the camera to show Carole's perspective
as they were being shuffled around did a
great job to heighten the tension great
job to keep the pacing up the pace of
the intro was awesome The Walking Dead
will do that sometimes where they switch
up their intros we're like last week you
had that funny song playing over Carol's
intro this week is crazy tension and
military jargon over the radios you get
the sense that the Savior's are way more
militarized than the survivors number 8
WTF Carol starts flipping her [ __ ]
hyperventilating and it's really hard to
I love the way they tease this because
you're like is something really wrong
with her is she faking it Melissa
McBride was on fire this week it wasn't
until she was messing with the cross
that I got the sense that she was just
pretending she was trying to set up a
scenario that would allow her to escape
and who do Carol was so good at
impressions this impression here feeble
Carol is like season 5 Gabriel she's
playing the super religious coward which
was basically Gabriel in season 5 now
Gabriel is more like Sam Jackson and
Pulp Fiction number 7 WTF Paula vs.
Maggie's baby anything that's happy
about Carol and Maggie apologists
immediately jumps on which is kind of
funny she's like darkest timeline Carol
so any positivity that you try to put
out there
she would just immediately shoot in the
face but number six WTF her boyfriend or
bed mate or heavy want to think about it
flips his [ __ ] knocks her out and then
goes for Carol for shooting him so this
is really where Carol and Maggie try to
start pruning Polly to their cause like
look we don't we don't want this to end
in bloodshed nobody has to die let's
make a bargain with Rick thank you for
helping us and for a minute you actually
believe that it's gonna work until Polly
just keeps shooting it down this is all
[ __ ] cut to number six WTF the other
young woman's Savior versus Maggie you
are not the good guys we're the good
guys I love the way Maggie tried to get
that story out of her too yeah I tried
to still gasps try to find my man we
were gonna name the baby after my father
but it's hard to tell if Maggie is just
putting on a show or if she's being
honest in all these moments I thought
she was trying to be honest right till
the end when she started stabbing
everyone in the face number five WTF
Polly explains her backstory she's from
Washington DC she got stuck with her
boss she had a pretty humdrum job but
she had kind of an idealistic view
before the apocalypse hit when [ __ ] got
crazy
she preemptively killed her boss to keep
him from being a liability and they just
took it on the road and made up with the
Savior's at some point I stopped
counting the number of bodies after I
hit double digits so she's basically
Carol from last week Carol looking at
that number 18
I've killed 18 people darkest timeline
Carol in the title of the episode was
the same boat so it was like her and
Carol are in the same boat this moral
boat that they're in they're the same
person it's just that Carol the
protagonist tries to do something better
Holly's having none of it but I did like
the way she through Carol's principles
in her face you wouldn't want me to
stick to my principles
number four double yep ninja Carol way
more badass than ninja Jesus that
MacGyver music comes on and you know
[ __ ] is going down
Carol gets out in no time flat sneaks
around gets to Maggie and Maggie has the
most amazing response to Carol Carol's
like let's get out of here Maggie
she says the exact same thing she said
at the beginning of the episode Maggie
we need to go and for the second time
Maggie's like no we got to finish this
we got to kill them all number three WTF
killing the smoking woman they rigged
this awesome Walker trap wait a minute
I need to tie something up I love the
way they left him that little present
not
as cool as Daryl's RPG kill of the other
saviors they got a name drop in this
episode oh so that's what happened to
T's group way more ninja than Daryl's
kill but the fire came at the end number
two WTF Carroll versus poly so far this
season
Alicia Wits performance as this guest
star Polly this guest character is
probably my favorite all season just the
way all of her morality gets stripped
away as she and Carol are just at each
other's throats what are you afraid of
she's afraid of being the Terminator
again Polly gets impaled and then her
face starts getting ripped off I love
the way some of these people die on the
show it's just so gruesome and so
amazing to watch you can't look away
it's like staring at the Sun it burns
your eyes out of their sockets but it's
so amazing that you can't look away
so r.i.p polly you had one of the best
deaths on the show cut to number one WTF
we are all negan what the hell is that
supposed to mean if you haven't read the
comics
negan isn't so much like the governor
and that he's just a really awful person
that rules over a group he's more of an
idea that kind of bleeds into everyone's
head so thematically it's much closer to
being an actual cult
although negan doesn't really put
himself out as a god or anything like
that he probably thinks of himself as a
god but there's so much heavy-handed
religious imagery the Savior's the
rosary beads the Carol had it with the
cross even she was clutching it so
tightly at the end that her hand bled so
I'd have to say it wasn't a WTF moment
but it was a nice tag end to after Beth
died last season when Daryl just
completely shut down as a human being in
Carol had to just like go and comfort
him and hug him that was kind of
Darrell's job in this episode it was his
turn to comfort Carol it's a nice pookie
moment there you doing okay you all
right no I am definitely not okay let me
know in the comments though what was
your favorite moment from this episode
Maggie going crazy
Carol going on ninja trying to be feeble
there was so much psychological drama
going on in the episode it wasn't one of
those big action episodes with RPGs
blowing up groups of people but the
kills were just as spectacular just as
gruesome and it's almost seemed like
because of this experience the
characters have done a 180 like Maggie
is the new Carol and Carol is the new
Maggie now I know they did a lot of
Savior stuff there weren't too many
Easter eggs from the comics aside from
that we
Arni can think that was like a little
bit from the comics this is about as
close as they got obviously they're
putting off actually showing negan for a
while that guy was definitely not negan
so Rick probably thinks it's all done
now like oh we killed negan it's all
over
nobody's gonna come looking for us
what's gonna happen next week is there
still a couple TV shows that are on
break so I'll be doing bonus videos for
that stuff like flash and arrow my
Gotham video will post on my Facebook
page there's a link for that in the
description I still got a lot of
questions about that but what I'm
thinking is is the next episode of The
Walking Dead will be relatively calm
like the calm before the storm and then
the last two episodes will just be off
the charts negan craziness and giveaway
time congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner Morgan white you win a
$20 Amazon gift card be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details I am
so excited The Walking Dead has never
been better than it is right now so
while you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click here for my Captain
America Civil War Black Panther video
and you can click here for all my other
Walking Dead videos thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight